if you look at the Nordic countries
Finland Sweden Norway Denmark Iceland
you have five countries they are all
different in many ways but there is one
very strong common factor these five
countries all have very competitive free
market economies and in every
international ranking they are among the
top nations in that respect and their
economic success in recent decades
demonstrates that the Nordic free market
economies perform extraordinary well
they have produced global companies that
dominate many other parts of the world
but at the same time these five Nordic
countries have developed a social
welfare system where everybody
irrespective of their income and Klaus
gets the same right to education to
health care and to equal treatment in
any economic way this coexistence of a
social welfare society where the right
to education and health care is equally
distributed throughout society is one of
the pillar of our economic and business
success so you cannot find any business
organization in any of the Nordic
countries which is advocating that we
should decrease this social welfare
system on the contrary the prominent
business leaders of our countries
realize that the evolution of this
social welfare system in terms of
Education and healthcare is one of the
major reasons why the Nordic businesses
have been globally so successful and why
why our market economies have grown so
aggressively why because if we have
honest
starla system that a cares of the sick
when they need it and allow every kid to
be educated to the fullness of its
potential the business leaders can
concentrate on the business they don't
have to worry about the health insurance
and everything that goes with this
complicated system where you don't have
a universal educational or health rights
so the Nordic formula not just the
Icelandic one but also from Norway
Sweden Finland and Denmark has created
what the economist the preeminent weekly
economic newspaper in the world deemed a
few months ago perhaps their most
successful economic models in the last
few decades so when my American friends
call it socialism in a very negative
tone I asked them looked at our business
record look at our economic record look
at the growth rate look at the
prosperity look at the global companies
look at the innovation that takes place
within this framework and if you do that
the evidence is absolutely clear to
provide everybody with the right to
education and health care is a formula
for economic and business success
you